c'est devenu un symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne
en banlieue de Helson
l'aéroport de tchernobyvecane guerre
plus qu'un champ de carcasse de métal
tordu et calciné un cimetière de
véhicules militaires russes les Russes
ont occupé l'aéroport dès le début de la
guerre mais c'est une occupation qui
s'est avéré coûteuse
ils y ont sacrifié hélicoptère blindé et
deux généraux dans des attaques
ukrainiennes ciblées parfois
quotidiennes
dit-il il le faut bien sûr je ne suis
pas fier de ce que l'aéroport a subi
c'est un problème il faudra restaurer
l'Ukraine mais ce qu'on leur imposé ce
coup dur oui j'en suis fier mon groupe
d'amis et moi avons fait ce que nous
pouvions avec les moyens que nous avions
quand Alexander parle de son groupe
d'amis il parle des partisans de simples
civils pour la plupart fidèle à
l'Ukraine et prise au piège par
l'occupation de Epson mais qui ont
combattu à leur façon
non seulement notre groupe est
responsable de ça ici mais il était
également l'un de ceux qui s'occupaient
de transmettre des données sur
l'équipement sur les mouvements de
l'armée et les positions de l'armée
russe
le 24 février dernier alors que les
premiers missiles russes frappaient la
capitale Kiev Vlad et son père se sont
rendus dans les bureaux de recrutement
de la défense territoriale pour se
porter volontaire mais personne s'est
retrouvé encerclé avant même qu'il ne
puisse prendre les armes
territoriale s'est retrouvée seule ici
nous étions encerclé dit-il
nous avons reçu l'ordre de nous
disperser parce que nous ne pouvions pas
nous battre avec des véhicules blindés
des armes automatiques et des grenades
à ne pas savoir quoi faire pour être
utile sans pour autant pouvoir quitter
la ville son père il lui était recherché
dans ce nouveau monde russe c'est par
des amis qu'il a eu vent des activités
des partisans
de cadira vivaient à cante vlades
pendant 3 jours je me suis baladé sur
cette rue j'ai observé cet édifice j'ai
cherché à comprendre dans lequel des
bâtiments il viv
occupé par les soldats tchétchène a été
frappé avec des missiles highmers tout
juste après qu'il ait fait son rapport
aujourd'hui Vlad porte fièrement la
tenue militaire mais sous l'Occupation
il voulait plus que tout se faire
discret
vous dormez et vous rêvez que les Russes
vous pourchasse se rappellent Vlad
qu'ils entrent chez vous vous essayez de
vous cacher et à ce moment-là vous vous
réveillez dans la nuit au son des
moteurs de leur camion camase de leur
blinder ou des camions oral et vous
sortez de cet enfer dans votre rêve à
cette réalité terrible
ce cauchemar Alexander l'a vécu éveillé
ses activités clandestines l'ont mené
jusqu'ici en août dernier
il n'avait pas encore revu les murs et
les barbelés de la prison ou des soldats
russes lui ont infligé toutes sortes de
châtiments corporels pendant 17 jours
avec leur bottes et des matraques sur
tout le corps se souvient Alexander il
s'acharnait sur ma jambe je ne sais pas
pourquoi
Alexander se décrit aujourd'hui comme un
invalide sa blessure la plus profonde
c'est en lui qui la porte
ceux qui sont passés par ici des
familles ordinaires parfois surtout il
pense à ceux qui ne sont jamais
ressortis
par ici et il y a encore des gens qui
sont détenus qui n'ont pas été libérés
mes collègues qui sont encore en
détention ils les ont déplacés ailleurs
dans la région de Herson qu'ils occupent
toujours à calanques
ils ont été écrits dans l'une des
cellules de détention et de torture des
autorités russes c'est le fils d'Irina
serie qui lui raconte avoir froid comme
un chien ne vouloir que dormir il n'en
peut plus
ma petite fille a eu 2 ans le 6 octobre
dit-elle c'est le jour où il l'ont
emmené en Crimée
son fils un militaire expérimenté était
coincé à Hassan dès les premières heures
de l'occupation Sergi c'est donner pour
mission de soutenir l'effort de guerre
de l'Ukraine dans le plus grand des
secrets
j'ai essayé de l'arrêter dit Sacha je
l'ai prévenu j'ai voulu empêcher ce qui
pouvait lui arriver
a été interrogé sans relâche par les
autorités russes désormais aux commandes
Helson Sacha ses deux filles et sa mère
ont dû déménager Distel pour éviter de
subir le même sorte
de petites notes cachées dans des
chaussettes
sont intarissables sur les exploits
militaires de Sergi mais ce n'est pas
que par fierté ou orgueil c'est aussi
par peur
c'est qu'il soit traité comme un civil
et que les Russes ne mettent pas son nom
sur une liste d'échanges de prisonniers
parce que dans ce cas-ci c'est un civil
militaire Sergi est un véritable héros
sur les deux femmes
tous les habitants de Helson qui se sont
accrochés à la ville sont aussi des
héros ils ont enduré résister et garder
espoir